gráfica una recta que tenga una
pendiente positiva y menor que la
pendiente de azul ahora vamos a pensar
por un segundo que significa pendiente
si tú escuchas la palabra pendiente en
tu vida cotidiana seguramente te estás
refiriendo a qué tan inclinado está algo
por ejemplo la pendiente de una pista de
esquí así por ejemplo esta recta que
tenemos aquí de color naranja no está
nada inclinada está plana así que
decimos que tiene una pendiente de 0
otra forma de verlo es si x aumentan
entonces qué le pasa y bueno te puedes
dar cuenta que ya no cambia por lo tanto
esta recta tiene una pendiente de 0
ahora si la recta de naranja la movemos
un poco de esta forma vamos a moverla a
algo así bueno entonces tiene una
pendiente positiva porque tú te puedes
dar cuenta que cuando x vale menos 5 que
vale 5 y ahora que nosotros nos movimos
supongamos para acá cuando x vale 5 que
vale en este caso otro
por lo tanto cuando x aumenta y también
aumenta lo que quiere decir que esta
recta tiene una pendiente positiva ahora
si nosotros movemos este punto a un poco
más para arriba bueno entonces tenemos
una pendiente más positiva y ahora mismo
vemos un poco más para arriba tenemos
una pendiente más grande y ahora nos
movemos hasta por acá bueno tenemos una
pendiente mucho más grande porque quiero
que te des cuenta que cuando x aumenta y
aumenta de una manera muy rápida nos
estamos moviendo hacia arriba de una
manera muy muy rápida y por lo tanto
tenemos una pendiente muy muy positiva
ahora aquí tenemos a una pendiente menos
positiva
aquí una menos positiva hay que una
menos positiva y bueno podríamos quedar
este para acá es decir que tenemos una
pendiente de cero y si nosotros movemos
ahora a esta recta para acá
date cuenta que tenemos una pendiente
negativa porque cuando x aumenta y está
disminuyendo por ejemplo si ponemos
justo aquí este punto en este punto x
vale menos
y vale 8 y después de que x aumenta
hasta 6 entonces el valor de y baja
hasta 6 por lo tanto la pendiente es
negativa porque ya está decreciendo
fíjate que aunque x está creciendo y
está disminuyendo por lo tanto esta es
una pendiente negativa pero ahora lo que
a nosotros nos piden es graficar una
recta que tenga una pendiente que sea
positiva y menor que la pendiente de la
recta azul si te das cuenta la recta
azul tiene una pendiente positiva porque
cuando x aumenta ya también aumenta por
ejemplo aquí cuando x toma valores
negativos
bueno pues tenemos un valor también
negativo en james y después cuando x
toma algunos valores positivos que toma
también algunos valores positivos por lo
tanto está aumentando x y aumentando el
james lo que quiere decir que la recta
azul tiene una pendiente positiva pero
ahora no están pidiendo que esta recta
naranja tenga una pendiente que sea
positiva y en primer lugar está
pendiente no es positiva por lo tanto
tenemos a una pendiente de 0 y si nos
bajamos para acá tenemos una pendiente
positiva pero lo que queremos es que sea
menor que la pendiente de la recta azul
si te das cuenta aquí tenemos una
pendiente menor que esta recta azul por
acá tenemos una pendiente muy grande y
por lo tanto tenemos una pendiente mayor
que la recta de azul y bueno si nosotros
retrocedemos por aquí tenemos casi la
misma pendiente y en este caso tenemos
una pendiente que es positiva pero es
menor que esta recta de azul entonces se
vería más o menos así así que recuerda
si quieres tener una pendiente de cero
entonces estaríamos justo por camps que
es tener una pendiente negativa entonces
estaríamos como por acá pero nosotros lo
que queremos es una pendiente positiva y
que sea menor que la pendiente de esta
recta azul y por lo tanto esta sería una
de las formas en la que tenemos la
respuesta que nosotros estamos buscando
y por lo tanto es hora de comprobar
respuesta y correcto